not in here turn on this damn a/c mmm
because I can afford air-conditioning
now here we go let's put that [ __ ] down
from 78 to 77 oh man I need to get a job
[Music]
hey what is going on everybody how was
your week
have you had a rough week let me ask you
something somebody mistreat you huh who
are they what do they live
give me I want names if they mess with
my family being messy with me so let's
go to the house fine what Dave lives
okay we should probably find with a lid
first before we go to their house it's
all sight homie i'ma come up straight
and a face like this and be like I'm
gonna beat your kids ass well your kids
that cuz you cut a big well everybody I
just got off a plane from Denver from
another send foods episode and you guys
haven't sent me this article so uh let's
get right into it
article love that's not even a saying
you dumb so the title of this article is
a woman named marijuana Pepsi earns her
PhD with a dissertation on uncommon
names what what universe am i living in
are you marijuana pet last week we just
did a video about a kid named duck
oldest to ever do it
I saw her half the fear of me having
children isn't even the part where I
have to raise them it's the part where I
have to name them because you can't do
it with these regular biblical last
names anymore
you gotta think outside the damn box all
right my kid's name Cookie Monster so I
mean her dissertation topic to no
surprise according to the article was
black names in white classrooms teacher
behavior and student perceptions
I mean clearly this was born out of her
personal experience with her uncommon
name well now when you read the article
she talks about her personal plight with
her being named you know buds McGee
marijuana Pepsi also mentioned the
article that she challenged a professor
who asked about the origin of her name
saying you didn't ask anyone else that
why are you asking me my name is
marijuana thank you
okay well let's talk about it you know
just off the top without reading her
dissertation or anything like that I'm
pretty sure that we all can agree that
somebody's name does have an effect on
how you perceived it and specifically
when it comes to like even Asian
communities or black communities
you know a lot of us didn't really have
typical American names and when people
would hear these names they kind of
already have a preconceived notion about
who we are right and let me just give
you an example when I give you this
example you really do have to be honest
with yourself because I grew up with
girls who were named like Shan Isha
Zakia
and when people would hear those type of
names I'm pretty sure that they already
had this thought of who they were and
what their intelligence level was and
what their background was without even
getting to know I'm not saying
everybody's like that but if I could
speak to that point like remember that
MADtv character boniva halifa Latifah
sharifa Jackson I'm not reading too deep
into it but what I'm saying is is that
from that title of or her dissertation I
can already see what she's saying and I
could already feel and understand where
she's coming from cuz for me it makes
sense because I see a lot of people do a
version of this when they see like the
color your skin or your ethnic
background right like how many of you
out there know a friend that didn't grow
up around a single [ __ ] black person
but the moment one black person comes in
it's like yes I want to go fill up my
gas tank and dance some dual came out to
me I was like the [ __ ] starts
throwing up random gang signs and start
speaking and Bonnie's [ __ ] you look
like a deaf-mute put your [ __ ] hands
down suck but having said all that I
mean doctor marijuana Patsy come on you
have to understand there's a category
called uncommon names see your name
doesn't even belong to that category
like how are you gonna be called dr.
marijuana Pepsi and expect people not to
ask what the [ __ ] is up with that name
why are people so nosy oh it's just the
name David okay well [ __ ] it then my
name is anus nose mcdu pee diapers sup
y'all you're not gonna ask a few
questions about the origin of my name
but out of here of course you are I
would be upset if you didn't ask any
questions cuz if you did I would tell
you the craziest story about it I was
three years old I took off my diaper
slipped on a Tonka truck fell flat face
into my Dookie diaper ever since then
Mick knows me goopy diapers that's what
it is
I'm smelling [ __ ] ever since you know
always has the weirdest names and when
you don't know these people you kind of
expect them to tell you what their
actual
name is but they never do so that is a
weird man because y'all never give out
your real name and on top of that when
you're talking to normal people you
forget that you're not on a dance floor
like how many times have you went up to
somebody and you didn't know that they
were a dancer and they could have just
given you the regular name but they had
to go and be like tickle tickle what is
your real name you 46 year old braided
pop-locking jerusalem camel look ahead
it's like your life mission to make sure
everybody knows that you dance and [ __ ]
[ __ ] I met you at a Chase Bank
know the situation like I picture some
of these extra ass [ __ ] just
pop lock in at a Funeral [ __ ]
ooh body wave cash - or my daddy died
but anyways back to the article I gotta
say doc saying that your name is
uncommon has to be the biggest
understatement of the year listen I get
that you're tired of people always
asking about the origin of your name but
my god that's some beef you gotta settle
with your parents not us either sit down
with your mom and pops and just straight
up bass mom dad what the [ __ ] I get
Parrish is kind of sat in the room
before you born and they were like how
can I get my kid to struggle for the
rest of their life because this is what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna name my kid dick
skin more skin and every time somebody
asked about the origin of his name I'm
gonna teach him to get mad at them it'd
be so [ __ ] funny if everybody is
waiting for this amazing origin story
for your name but it just turned out
your dad was like a drug magician and he
just put two random names and his
[ __ ] top hat marijuana Pepsi Oh what
if your name was pepper your name would
be dr. pepper Pepsi and the article they
did have a couple of tweets where people
were kind of clowning on her for her
name which was obviously the problem
that she had her whole life so I don't
know if that helped the situation but
because of this article people were
actually empowered by it like for
example look at this tweet one woman
wrote as a woman named Shaniqua I
support this Big Ups to dr. marijuana
Pepsi some of my favorite people on
earth are quirky and have faced a lot of
adversity and I'm pretty sure with that
name especially as an adult you had the
opportunity to change it but you took
what most people would think is a
misfortune and you turned it into
something very fortuitous
wrote this dissertation at effect
in a very positive way so shoutouts to
you dr. marijuana Pepsi but your [ __ ]
name is weird
well guys that's about it see y'all next
time hey what is going on YouTube like I
said I don't know when these videos are
going up it really depends on the advice
that you ask the topics that you give
and the things that we will be doing cuz
it's based on your interactions in the
comments below and the things that you
said to the emails man remember to hit
that notification button and subscribe
because you guys already know that
algorithm has [ __ ] me because I've
been so inactive but genius brain
podcast is still up every Thursday and
Sundays so give that a listen to all
your audio platforms and check it out on
the youtubes baby I'll see y'all next
time
real soon